[Music]
what are you still doing here old man
i'm gonna [ __ ] you up
got it i got it
right
[Music]
ah
i started as a comedy writer in this
business so
no exercise at all and nobody i play a
dad
and i have this past but because of a
break-in
i re-engage with violence in my life i
knew that this was something that would
be really
challenging for me personally bob took
the challenge wholeheartedly
what are you still doing here oh man
i'm gonna mess you up
i knew that i had to go to a whole other
level if i wanted to actually do the
fighting and not get hurt
he knew that if he wants to play this
character
he has to pay the price to me the fun of
doing this
is to learn that new set of skills
there's this thing i gotta do
then you best go good we started in
november 2017 and he would learn how to
punch she would learn how to kick throne
and he would not quit i might have
over corrected
i wanted to commit completely and
go all the way into utterly unapologetic
rage
who are you me
i'm nobody
[Music]
you